I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi! All right. We are sitting across from each other. You guys, this is very exciting. Because 2022, we couldn't do this until now. Until now, I'm tearing up a little. It's so good to be back. It's so good to be back, lady. Today, we're talking about double date. It is season six, episode nine. It's written by Charlie Grandy, who is the writer famous for
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。嗨！好了。我们正面对面坐着。伙计们，这太令人兴奋了。因为在2022年，我们直到现在才能做到这一点。直到现在，我有点热泪盈眶了。能回来真是太好了。能回来真是太好了，女士。今天，我们要谈论的是“双重约会”。这是第六季第九集。它由查理·格兰迪编写，他是一位著名的编剧，以
boom roasted and directed by Seth Gordon. Here's your summary. Jim, Pam, Michael, and Pam's mom, Helene, all go out to lunch to celebrate Helene's birthday. This is the double date of double date. And it all goes well until Michael spirals out about Helene's real age and then he breaks up with her at her birthday lunch. Meanwhile, Dwight does nice things for everyone in the office in an attempt to get each of them to owe him a favor. Then he's going to cash in his favors to get Jim fired. But unfortunately for Dwight, Andy is also very good at favors. Andy will not owe you anything. I love it when he's like, you send me a wedding invitation. I respond. Yes. Invite me to your birthday. Boom. Accepted.
“砰，被烤了”而闻名，并由塞斯·戈登执导。这是你的摘要。吉姆、帕姆、迈克尔和帕姆的妈妈海琳一起出去吃午饭，庆祝海琳的生日。这就是“双重约会”中的双重约会。一切都很顺利，直到迈克尔因为海琳的真实年龄而失控，然后在她的生日午餐上与她分手。与此同时，德怀特在办公室里为每个人做善事，试图让每个人都欠他一个人情。然后他打算兑现他的人情，让吉姆被解雇。但不幸的是，安迪也非常擅长人情世故。安迪绝不会欠你任何东西。我喜欢他那样，你给我发了婚礼请柬。我回复。是的。邀请我参加你的生日。砰。接受。
Yes. Yeah. I would like that. That's a good quality. I mean, you know, you probably get a handwritten thank you card from Andy. You probably do. All right, let's get into fast facts. Fast fact number one is all about our director, Seth Gordon. You know, we said last week, we're going to get into some of these like heavy hitter directors and Seth is another one. Yeah. I loved Seth because he directed one of my favorite movies of all time, the documentary King of Kong, A Fistful of Quarters. It's so flipping good. It's so good. And we rewatched it as a family. Did you with the kids? If you do not know this documentary, you need to watch it immediately. It is about the world of competitive arcade gaming. Specifically,
是的。是的。我喜欢那样。那是一种很好的品质。我的意思是，你知道，你可能会从安迪那里收到一张手写的感谢卡。你可能会的。好了，让我们进入快速事实。第一个快速事实是关于我们的导演塞斯·戈登。你知道，我们上周说过，我们要介绍一些像这样的大牌导演，塞斯就是其中之一。是的。我喜欢塞斯，因为他执导了我最喜欢的电影之一，纪录片《金刚之王：一把四分之一》。它太棒了。太棒了。我们全家重温了它。你和孩子们一起看了吗？如果你不知道这部纪录片，你需要立即观看。它是关于竞技街机游戏的世界。具体来说，
it follows this just gentle hearted sweet guy named Steve Weebie in his attempt to beat the Donkey Kong high score, which was held for like 20 years by this guy, Billy Mitchell. Billy Mitchell is like the ultimate documentary villain. The story of these two guys battling it out to have the high score on Donkey Kong. I couldn't love him more. When he would go in his garage and practice. Yes. And his wife would like check in. Oh my gosh, you guys, it is such a wonderful story. You can find it on Prime Video and Apple TV. We watched on Prime. We had to buy it. I'm so glad we did. So Seth Gordon, he did everything on this movie. He directed it. He was the cinematographer. He edited it. And then he came and did our
它讲述了这个温柔善良的家伙史蒂夫·威比试图打破大金刚最高分的故事，这个纪录由这个叫比利·米切尔的家伙保持了大约20年。比利·米切尔就像终极纪录片反派。这两个家伙争夺大金刚最高分的故事。我再喜欢他不过了。当他去车库练习时。是的。他的妻子会去查看。天哪，伙计们，这是一个多么精彩的故事。你可以在Prime Video和Apple TV上找到它。我们在Prime上看了。我们不得不买它。我很高兴我们买了。所以塞斯·戈登，他在这部电影上做了一切。他执导了它。他是摄影师。他剪辑了它。然后他来了，做了我们的
show. So we got another documentary and film director. I looked through my digital clutter, lady. And I actually emailed a friend of mine saying how excited I was to have Seth on set. And that we were all really excited. And then I also said, and I have a day off because because of the double date story. And guess what I did with my day off? What? I did an episode of Yo Gabba Gabba. Oh, I remember that. Because my daughter loved the show and I went to the set. I got to play the school teacher. I had to sing about show and tell. Here it is. Oh my gosh, well done, Angela. Time for show and tell. I had to sing and dance. You know,
节目。所以我们又得到了一位纪录片和电影导演。我翻看了我的数字杂物，女士。我实际上给我的一个朋友发了电子邮件，说我有多兴奋能让塞斯在片场。我们都非常兴奋。然后我还说，因为双重约会的故事，我有一天假。你猜我休假那天做了什么？什么？我拍了一集《Yo Gabba Gabba》。哦，我记得那个。因为我女儿喜欢这个节目，我去了片场。我有幸扮演学校老师。我不得不唱关于展示和讲述的歌。在这里。天哪，干得好，安吉拉。是时候展示和讲述了。我不得不唱歌跳舞。你知道，
these are things I do not do, but it's what you do for your kids. Isabel is so excited that they gave me this great picture of her and I on set with all of the characters and I have it in my office. It's so cute. And everyone there was so nice. They were so much fun. It was one of the most fun days of work I've ever had. Every day on Yo Gabba Gabba was a theme day. And that day was birthday day. And you would come dressed as whatever your interpretation of that was. And this one gal came dressed as a cake, like fully a cake, like a hat and a skirt, but she was a tiered cake. You would wear that. You love a birthday. I do love a birthday.
这些是我不做的事情，但这是你为孩子做的事情。伊莎贝尔非常兴奋，他们给了我一张她和我在片场与所有角色的合影，我把它放在我的办公室里。太可爱了。那里每个人都很好。他们太有趣了。这是我工作过最有趣的日子之一。在《Yo Gabba Gabba》的每一天都是主题日。那天是生日日。你会打扮成你对那个主题的理解。这个女孩打扮成一个蛋糕，完全是一个蛋糕，像一顶帽子和一条裙子，但她是一个分层蛋糕。你会穿那个。你喜欢生日。我确实喜欢生日。
Should we start having theme days on our tape days here at Office Ladies? Is that a lot of pressure? It feels like a lot of pressure. Okay, we won't do it. Maybe once. We'll do one theme day. We'll do one. Sam, you have to participate. Everyone participates. I would love to.
我们应该开始在《办公室》女士的录制日进行主题日吗？那压力很大吗？感觉压力很大。好吧，我们不做了。也许一次。我们会做一个主题日。我们会做一个。萨姆，你必须参加。每个人都参加。我很乐意。
Okay. Theme day coming up. Well before we move to Fast Fact Number Two, let me also add that Seth Gordon has gone on to direct huge movies for Christmases, Horrible Bosses, Identity Theft and Baywatch. He's also directed a ton of television. I loved working with him. I loved him. So now Fast Fact Number Two is a location breakdown. Is it of the restaurant? Yes. I mean, so much of this episode takes place at this restaurant, Paparazzos. Not
好的。主题日即将到来。在进入第二个快速事实之前，我还想补充一点，塞斯·戈登后来执导了《圣诞夜惊魂》、《恶老板》、《身份窃贼》和《海滩救护队》等大片。他还执导了大量的电视节目。我喜欢和他一起工作。我喜欢他。现在第二个快速事实是地点细分。是关于餐厅的吗？是的。我的意思是，这一集的很多内容都发生在这家餐厅，Paparazzos。不是
a real restaurant. We made it up. We filmed it in Los Angeles at this place called Bistro Garden in Studio City. I was going to say, wait, I've driven past that. Yeah, I've eaten there. It's at the corner of Cold Water in Ventura. Oh yeah, with the big awning and the steps. Yes. Yes. It was all closed, but it was a really great restaurant.
一家真正的餐厅。我们编造的。我们在洛杉矶工作室城一个叫Bistro Garden的地方拍摄的。我正想说，等等，我开车经过那里。是的，我在那里吃过饭。它在冷水和文图拉的拐角处。哦，是的，有大遮阳篷和台阶。是的。是的。它都关门了，但那是一家非常棒的餐厅。
When I reached out to our writer on this episode, Charlie Grandy, to ask him about some of his memories that we might be able to share, he reminded me that there was a giant water main break on Cold Water Canyon Road that exploded and flooded the whole area. Whole street. Yes. I remember that. And that was like the day before we were supposed to shoot in this area. I used to live off this road off Cold Water Canyon.
当我联系这一集的编剧查理·格兰迪询问他的一些我们可能分享的记忆时，他提醒我，冷水峡谷路有一根巨大的水管破裂，爆炸并淹没了整个区域。整条街。是的。我记得那个。那就像我们应该在这个区域拍摄的前一天。我曾经住在冷水峡谷外面的这条路上。
There was one way in and one way out of my neighborhood. And it was this road where this water main broke. Randy Cordray confirmed that this happened and it caused a huge problem with this intersection. There were hundreds of thousands of gallons of water. It was about four feet deep. There was all this traffic. It took like three days to clean it up. Some guy had to be rescued from his car.
我的社区只有一条路进，一条路出。就是这条水管破裂的路。兰迪·科德雷证实了这一点，它导致了这个十字路口的巨大问题。有几十万加仑的水。大约四英尺深。到处都是交通。清理它花了大约三天时间。有人不得不从车里被救出来。
All the businesses along that street flooded and had to be closed. And some of them had to be renovated and some didn't even come back because it was too much damage. And you know what I remember? I remember right on Cold Water, a few days after the flood, there was a sinkhole. Yes. And they had a giant hole in the ground. Lady, I found a picture of it.
那条街上的所有企业都被淹了，不得不关闭。其中一些不得不翻新，有些甚至因为损坏太严重而没有回来。你知道我记得什么吗？我记得就在冷水路上，洪水过后几天，有一个天坑。是的。地上有一个巨大的洞。女士，我找到了一张照片。
This was in the LA Times. Yes. It was crazy. And then they had to fix the sinkhole by laying these big metal plate things on the ground. And when you drove over them, it was like, yeah, it was scary. And then later they had to fix this water main and you had to have a special pass to even drive on this road. You had to prove that you were a resident with only this road to access your home.
这在《洛杉矶时报》上。是的。太疯狂了。然后他们不得不通过在地上铺设这些大金属板来修复天坑。当你开车经过它们时，就像，是的，很吓人。后来他们不得不修理这根水管，你必须有特别通行证才能在这条路上开车。你必须证明你是居民，只有这条路可以进入你的家。
So we got the special car passes. The traffic was a son of a bull. It was. Amazingly enough, the bistro where we were shooting did not flood and they found a way that we could access it from this back road and we still shot that day. Wow. Yeah. All right.
所以我们拿到了特别的汽车通行证。交通简直糟透了。确实。令人惊讶的是，我们拍摄的小酒馆没有被淹，他们找到了一种我们可以从这条后路进入的方法，我们那天还是拍了。哇。是的。好了。
Fast fact number three, Angela. The other memory that Charlie Grandi shared was that he got a blackberry during this episode. He finally upgraded his flip phone, but he said he did not know how to set it up. So he asked John to help him to set up his blackberry on set because John was the voice of blackberry. Oh yeah. John had one. He had to know how to use it because he was like part of a campaign.
第三个快速事实，安吉拉。查理·格兰迪分享的另一个记忆是，他在这一集期间得到了一个黑莓手机。他终于升级了他的翻盖手机，但他说是他不知道如何设置它。所以他请约翰在片场帮他设置他的黑莓手机，因为约翰是黑莓的代言人。哦，是的。约翰有一个。他必须知道如何使用它，因为他就像是竞选活动的一部分。
Yeah. I found an audio clip. Oh. What's this? The new blackberry? You've seen blackberries before. It's no McDeal. Maybe one quick peek just to see what all the fuss is about.
是的。我找到了一个音频片段。哦。这是什么？新的黑莓？你以前见过黑莓。没什么大不了的。也许看一眼，看看大家都在吵什么。
Whoa. So this was when blackberry was getting away from the little buttons and they were just like going to become a touchscreen blackberry. So that's why he's like, whoa. He has a really good voice for that. He's done tons of voiceovers. I know. So anyway, I loved that Charlie had a memory that during different setups, he'd be like
哇。所以这是黑莓摆脱小按钮，即将成为触摸屏黑莓的时候。所以这就是为什么他说，哇。他的声音真的很适合那个。他做过大量的配音。我知道。所以无论如何，我喜欢查理有一个记忆，在不同的设置中，他会像
getting John to set up a new blackberry for him. It's so funny because when you're talking to someone and they all of a sudden tell you something and all of these memories flood back. Yeah. So that's now happened twice today. First of all, the sinkhole. I remember the sinkhole. Secondly, I remember getting my blackberry and having Rain help me.
让约翰为他设置一个新的黑莓手机。这太有趣了，因为当你和某人交谈时，他们突然告诉你一些事情，所有这些记忆都涌了回来。是的。所以今天已经发生了两次。首先，天坑。我记得那个天坑。其次，我记得我拿到黑莓手机并让雷恩帮我。
Yeah. Rain got so frustrated with me because he was like, Angela, you're not listening. Yeah, because Rain was the first one to get one. Yeah. I remember Rain helped me set up my blackberry. Well, that's all I got for Fast Facts. Well, I loved your Fast Facts. They took me down memory lane and this is such a fun episode.
是的。雷恩对我感到非常沮丧，因为他说，安吉拉，你没在听。是的，因为雷恩是第一个得到它的人。是的。我记得雷恩帮我设置了我的黑莓手机。好吧，这就是我关于快速事实的所有内容。好吧，我喜欢你的快速事实。它们带我走进了记忆之路，这一集太有趣了。
I was so delighted by it. I can't wait for us to just get right into it. I had forgotten about so much of it, so I loved it too. Well, how about this? Let's go to break because when we come back, lady, I brought in one of my journals. Oh. Oh. The stay is awesome.
我对此感到非常高兴。我迫不及待地想让我们直接进入它。我忘记了其中的很多内容，所以我也很喜欢它。好吧，这个怎么样？让我们去休息一下，因为当我们回来时，女士，我带了一本我的日记。哦。哦。待在这里太棒了。
Dwayne's are going to get spicy. We are back. Dwight is walking around with, I want you to know, what I think was a very nice basket because I noticed a basket. He's got all of these beautiful bagels from H&H Bagel in New York and he has started his favorite campaign. Yeah. I'll have you know, H&H Bagels is a real place in New York.
德怀恩的要变得辛辣了。我们回来了。德怀特走来走去，我想让你知道，我认为是一个非常好的篮子，因为我注意到了一个篮子。他有所有这些来自纽约H&H百吉饼店的美丽百吉饼，他已经开始了最喜欢的竞选活动。是的。我会让你知道，H&H百吉饼是纽约的一个真实地方。
It's very famous for having the best bagels and this is also not the first time that H&H Bagels has been featured on a television show. What was the other show? Seinfeld. Oh, yeah. And I have an audio clip. Oh my gosh. Great news.
它以拥有最好的百吉饼而闻名，这也是H&H百吉饼第一次出现在电视节目中。另一个节目是什么？《宋飞正传》。哦，是的。我有一个音频片段。天哪。好消息。
Yeah, the strike's been settled. I'm going back to work. What strike? H&H Bagels. That's where I worked. You worked? Bagels? Yeah, look.
是的，罢工已经解决了。我要回去工作了。什么罢工？H&H百吉饼。那是我工作的地方。你工作？百吉饼？是的，看。
Still on my business card. Yeah, we've been on strike for 12 years. I've never seen those guys picketing out there but I haven't seen them in a long time. Yeah, well H&H would let us use their bathroom while we were picketing. Put a crimp in our solidarity. Your demands? Yeah, 5.35 an hour and that's what they're paying now. I believe that's the new minimum wage.
还在我的名片上。是的，我们已经罢工12年了。我从来没见过那些家伙在那里纠察，但我很久没见过他们了。是的，好吧，H&H会让我们在纠察时使用他们的浴室。在我们的团结中造成了阻碍。你的要求？是的，每小时5.35美元，这就是他们现在支付的工资。我相信那是新的最低工资。
And now you know who to thank for that. All right, I gotta go. Why didn't you ever mention this? Well, Jerry, I didn't want you to know I was out of work. It's embarrassing. So this is the storyline that suddenly you find out that Kramer had a job, that he's been on strike and it was H&H Bagels and he goes back to the bagel place and he gets his job back. He doesn't know, like he gets there and I ended up watching the episode.
现在你知道该感谢谁了。好了，我得走了。你为什么从来没提过这个？好吧，杰瑞，我不想让你知道我失业了。这很尴尬。所以这就是突然发现克莱默有一份工作，他一直在罢工，那是H&H百吉饼，他回到百吉饼店，拿回了他的工作。他不知道，就像他到了那里，我最终看了那一集。
I can't tell. And he gets there and he's like, Raisin Bagel. We're putting raisins in them. And you're like, yeah, I mean the Raisin Bagel. He's like, all right, I can do it. It was very funny. But I'll have you know that the bagels that Dwight is passing out were not actually H&H Bagels from New York. They were from a place called Western Bagel in Vinay's.
我看不出来。他到了那里，他说，葡萄干百吉饼。我们在里面放葡萄干。你说，是的，我的意思是葡萄干百吉饼。他说，好吧，我能做到。这非常有趣。但我会让你知道，德怀特分发的百吉饼实际上不是来自纽约的H&H百吉饼。它们来自维奈一个叫西部百吉饼的地方。
Western Bagel is very good too. I've been there. I have a little something to share about H&H. What is it? Why are you reaching in a bag? I'm reaching for my journal. What? Get ready.
西部百吉饼也很好。我去过那里。我有一点关于H&H的事情要分享。是什么？你为什么伸手去拿包？我正在伸手拿我的日记。什么？准备好。
Okay. The first bagel I ever had was an H&H bagel and it was when I was interning on Late Night with Conan O'Brien. Stop it right now. This journal, it's a flower journal. It has many post-it notes sticking out of it, pages are falling out, and there is a Late Night with Conan O'Brien sticker. I got the sticker when I got the internship and I put it on my journal. I mean, I'm taking a picture of you, obviously. All right.
好的。我吃过的第一个百吉饼是H&H百吉饼，那是我在柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀实习的时候。现在就停下来。这本日记，它是一本花朵日记。它上面贴着许多便利贴，页面正在掉落，还有一个柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀的贴纸。我得到实习机会时得到了这个贴纸，我把它贴在我的日记上。我的意思是，我显然在给你拍照。好了。
Before we turn to the page where I talk about my first bagel experience, I interned on Conan O'Brien. Years later, over a decade later, I was asked to be a guest. It was a full circle life moment because I went from the person who was getting everyone's coffee to actually being a guest. And I brought my journal when I was a guest and I read this on Late Night with Conan. Ready? Yes. I cannot wait. All right.
在我们翻到我谈论我第一次百吉饼经历的那一页之前，我在柯南·奥布莱恩那里实习。多年后，十多年后，我被邀请成为嘉宾。这是一个完整的生命时刻，因为我从那个为每个人买咖啡的人变成了真正的嘉宾。我做嘉宾时带了我的日记，我在柯南深夜秀上读了它。准备好了吗？是的。我迫不及待了。好了。
Turning to the page. Here we go. Tomorrow night is Conan's first year anniversary party at the Museum of Modern Art. Lots of important people, stars, NBC folks, and the interns get to go. Wow. Details later. What am I? Details later to myself?
翻到那一页。我们开始吧。明天晚上是柯南在现代艺术博物馆的一周年纪念派对。很多重要人物，明星，NBC的人，实习生都可以去。哇。细节稍后。我是什么？细节稍后对自己说？
This is my journal. I go on to say. And there are serious food perks to interning here. I get a free meal with the writers and I had my first bagel. It's basically bread that looks like a donut. No, you did not just describe what a bagel is in your journal to myself. Just in case you forget later. Just in case I forget.
这是我的日记。我继续说。在这里实习有严重的食物福利。我和编剧们一起吃免费餐，我吃了我的第一个百吉饼。它基本上是看起来像甜甜圈的面包。不，你没有在你的日记里对自己描述百吉饼是什么。以防你以后忘记。以防我忘记。
Just in case someone finds this journal someday and they're curious, what is a bagel? And they're curious what's going to happen at Conan's party. Details later. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Keep going, please. No. That's it?
以防有人有一天发现这本日记，他们很好奇，什么是百吉饼？他们很好奇柯南的派对会发生什么。细节稍后。是的。哦，是的。请继续。不。就这样？
No, please. Okay. Please. Let's see. Did you ever write the details later? I did. I don't know if I can read them. Okay.
不，请。好的。请。让我们看看。你写过细节稍后吗？我写了。我不知道我能不能读它们。好的。
This is what the journal becomes just for you. Yeah. Okay. In a nutshell, Conan's party, the interns had to work the front door. So you got to go. But also. I had to work. We had a list of names of people who could come in.
这就是日记为你变成的样子。是的。好的。简而言之，柯南的派对，实习生必须在前门工作。所以你可以去。但也。我必须工作。我们有一份可以进来的人的名字清单。
After working the party, we got to come inside at the end and we got to have drinks. We all got tutored. Oh, my gosh. Wait, can you go back and read your description of what a bagel is one more time? I just want to hear it again. Yes. And there's some serious food perks to interning here. I get a free meal with the writers and I had my first bagel.
在派对工作后，我们可以在最后进来，我们可以喝饮料。我们都得到了辅导。天哪。等等，你能回去再读一遍你对百吉饼的描述吗？我只是想再听一遍。是的。在这里实习有严重的食物福利。我和编剧们一起吃免费餐，我吃了我的第一个百吉饼。
It's basically bread that looks like a donut. Okay. I'm sorry, you guys got what? At the party? What did you guys get? Tutored. What time period does this take place? You guys, this is 1994.
它基本上是看起来像甜甜圈的面包。好的。对不起，你们得到了什么？在派对上？你们得到了什么？辅导。这段时间是什么时候？伙计们，这是1994年。
I got tutored. I got tutored on free drinks after working the door all night. I'm sorry. I need a mug that has a picture of a bagel. And underneath it says it's basically bread shaped like a donut. There you guys go. My first H&H bagel. And now you know how lame I was in my 20s.
我得到了辅导。我在整晚工作后得到了免费饮料的辅导。对不起。我需要一个有百吉饼图片的杯子。下面写着它基本上是像甜甜圈形状的面包。你们去吧。我的第一个H&H百吉饼。现在你知道我20多岁时有多蹩脚了。
Your journal reads like how they write Michael Scott's journal. It does, lady. It's amazing. It's amazing. Oh, my gosh, you guys. Please bring it back again some other time. Please just keep reading it. Oh, my gosh.
你的日记读起来就像他们写迈克尔·斯科特的日记一样。确实，女士。太神奇了。太神奇了。天哪，伙计们。请改天再带回来。请继续读它。天哪。
Oh, boy. Okay. All right. All right. Back to the episode. I'm sorry. Okay. Back to the episode.
哦，男孩。好的。好了。好了。回到这一集。对不起。好的。回到这一集。
You know when Dwight went in to offer Michael the bagels? Yes. And Michael claims he isn't hungry because he had two fish stick sandwiches, which were an aphrodisiac. Right. But his lady friend declined. Yes. Dwight says something like, you're thinking of deer penis.
你知道德怀特进去给迈克尔百吉饼的时候吗？是的。迈克尔声称他不饿，因为他吃了两个鱼条三明治，那是催情剂。对。但他的女性朋友拒绝了。是的。德怀特说了一些类似的话，你在想鹿鞭。
I was thinking of oysters. There are many things that are aphrodisiacs. Oh, no. I sense a deep dive. But I was most curious. No, you did not type deer penis aphrodisiac. I did type is deer penis an aphrodisiac. Oh, Lord Jesus.
我在想牡蛎。有很多东西是催情剂。哦，不。我感觉到了一次深入挖掘。但我最好奇。不，你没有打鹿鞭催情剂。我确实打了鹿鞭是催情剂吗。哦，主耶稣。
It is. What? It's real. Come on. Yeah. It goes all the way back to Hippocrates. Recommended deer penis as a solution to quote resolving sexual difficulties. But that's not all.
它是。什么？是真的。得了吧。是的，它一直追溯到希波克拉底。推荐鹿鞭作为解决引用解决性困难的方案。但这还不是全部。
According to Wikipedia, in traditional Chinese medicine, deer penis is thought to have like other therapeutic properties. There's something called deer penis wine. No. Yep. No. Yep. You can get it for about $12 a glass.
根据维基百科，在中医中，鹿鞭被认为具有其他治疗特性。有一种东西叫鹿鞭酒。不。是的。不。是的。你可以花大约12美元一杯买到它。
Get away from me with your deer penis wine. It supposedly can help heal athletic injuries. Well, I'm not athletic, so. But if you don't want deer penis wine, you could have three penis wine. What? Three penises. Who's three penises?
带着你的鹿鞭酒离我远点。它据说可以帮助治愈运动损伤。好吧，我不运动，所以。但如果你不想要鹿鞭酒，你可以喝三鞭酒。什么？三根阴茎。谁的三根阴茎？
In the wine. A seal penis. Stop it. A deer penis and a dog penis. Come on. Who is making wine out of a bunch of penises? I don't know, but you can get it. And since I was in studio today.
在酒里。海豹阴茎。停下。鹿鞭和狗鞭。得了吧。谁在用一堆阴茎酿酒？我不知道，但你可以得到它。既然我今天在工作室。
No, no, no, no. I'm not drinking it. You did not bring deer penis wine. No. I didn't. I didn't. Oh my God. I didn't.
不，不，不，不。我不喝它。你没有带鹿鞭酒。不。我没有。我没有。天哪。我没有。天哪。
I was just kidding. Oh my God. But I did find a website called ale sessions, and this person did drink three penis wine, and I thought I'd read you the description. Okay. Here's what they said. Quote.
我只是在开玩笑。天哪。但我确实找到了一个叫ale sessions的网站，这个人确实喝了三鞭酒，我想读给你听描述。好的。这是他们说的。引用。
It's something along the lines of an expired port with a pungent vinegar taste and some prune juice. And if you thought you'd get away with not tasting the three different penis profiles, you thought wrong. Also, it does not work in cocktails because it really just overpowers any possible combinations.
它有点像过期的波特酒，带有刺鼻的醋味和一些西梅汁。如果你以为你可以不品尝三种不同的阴茎特征就逃脱，那你就想错了。此外，它在鸡尾酒中不起作用，因为它真的只是压倒了任何可能的组合。
You think? The multiple penises overpower? The other flavors? The writer said, no one should consume more than just a sip of this concoction. If you truly are interested in tasting the weirdest of the weird,
你认为？多个阴茎压倒了？其他口味？作者说，没有人应该喝超过一口这种混合物。如果你真的有兴趣品尝最奇怪的奇怪东西，
three penis wine can generally be found in select Chinese grocers. It is sold on the shelves as it is classified as more of a natural herbal drink than alcohol. But honestly, don't drink this. It's not good, but that should be fairly obvious already.
三鞭酒通常可以在精选的中国杂货店找到。它在货架上出售，因为它被归类为比酒精更自然的草药饮料。但老实说，不要喝这个。它不好，但这应该已经很明显了。
I don't even know what to say. I am just thinking about these poor animals. How are they getting the penises? I can't. I didn't want to know, but what they do is they like soak the penises in something. There's also something called baby mouse wine.
我甚至不知道该说什么。我只是在想这些可怜的动物。他们是怎么得到阴茎的？我不能。我不想知道，但他们做的是他们把阴茎浸泡在什么东西里。还有一种东西叫幼鼠酒。
It's like a jar of baby mice, and then it ferments and then you drink it. For what? I don't know, but you know, when you're googling three penis wine, all these weird wines come up. Just weird drinks, you know.
它就像一罐幼鼠，然后发酵，然后你喝它。为了什么？我不知道，但你知道，当你谷歌三鞭酒时，所有这些奇怪的酒都会出现。只是奇怪的饮料，你知道。
There's articles about the weirdest drinks. Okay, note to self. Do not google about penis wine. Well, a sentence I never thought I would say out loud. Well, just like we weren't the first show to feature H&H bagels, we aren't the first show to mention deer penis.
有关于最奇怪饮料的文章。好的，给自己记下。不要谷歌关于阴茎酒。好吧，我从来没想过我会大声说出的一句话。好吧，就像我们不是第一个以H&H百吉饼为特色的节目一样，我们也不是第一个提到鹿鞭的节目。
Three penis wine was also a plotline of an episode of The League where they drink it. Well, I don't know what you thought you were going to hear today on Office Ladies. A bagel looks like a donut. There's penis wine. Anything can happen, guys.
三鞭酒也是《联盟》一集的情节，他们喝了它。好吧，我不知道你今天在《办公室》女士节目中会听到什么。百吉饼看起来像甜甜圈。有阴茎酒。什么都可能发生，伙计们。
Anything. I don't have much else for the rest of the episodes. So the scale is tipped to hear at the top of the show just with the cold open. I have two more things about this cold open. Oh my gosh, we're not done with the cold open? We're not. At 19 seconds,
任何事情。对于剩下的剧集，我没有太多其他内容。所以天平在节目开始时就倾斜了，仅仅是冷开场。关于这个冷开场，我还有两件事。天哪，我们还没做完冷开场？我们没有。在19秒，
I got a coffee mug callback. What's that? I love a coffee mug callback. Andy has his mug from Kelly's America's Got Talent Viewing Party sitting on his desk. Also, this was not the cold open in the shooting draft.
我得到了一个咖啡杯回调。那是什么？我喜欢咖啡杯回调。安迪桌上放着他从凯利的《美国达人》观看派对上拿来的杯子。此外，这不是拍摄草稿中的冷开场。
Really? Yeah, there was a whole different cold open. Here's what it said. Cold open, interior, Michael's office. Michael sits at his desk flipping through a small stack of pictures. He sees Jim walking by. Jim, Jim, you have to see this regarding the photo.
真的吗？是的，有一个完全不同的冷开场。这是它说的。冷开场，室内，迈克尔的办公室。迈克尔坐在桌子旁翻看一小叠照片。他看到吉姆走过。吉姆，吉姆，你必须看看这个关于照片的内容。
Do you know who that is? Jim. No, Michael. Come on, how can you not tell? The t-shirt, the jeans, Jim. Is it you? Michael. I'm flattered, but it's Johnny Depp.
你知道那是谁吗？吉姆。不，迈克尔。得了吧，你怎么可能看不出来？T恤，牛仔裤，吉姆。是你吗？迈克尔。我很荣幸，但那是约翰尼·德普。
Jim, really? Where did you take these? Michael, my condo complex. Jim, of course. And what was he doing there? Michael, keep this on the down low, but he was moving in. Jim.
吉姆，真的吗？你在哪里拍的这些？迈克尔，我的公寓大楼。吉姆，当然。他在那里做什么？迈克尔，保持低调，但他要搬进来了。吉姆。
Right, because I read in People that Johnny Depp was looking for a two-bedroom in Scranton. Michael, I'm totally flipping. You know my idea for a Fourth Pirates movie, right? So this goes on and on. Michael is convinced that Johnny Depp has moved in and is his neighbor.
对，因为我在《人物》杂志上读到约翰尼·德普正在斯克兰顿寻找两居室。迈克尔，我完全疯了。你知道我关于第四部《加勒比海盗》电影的想法，对吧？所以这没完没了。迈克尔确信约翰尼·德普已经搬进来，是他的邻居。
And as it turns out, when he goes to see Johnny Depp's mailbox, it says M.Schulman. So it's not Johnny Depp. I'm surprised Michael doesn't think that's an alias. It is a really funny scene. And we shot it, and it also includes Michael's impression of Jack Sparrow.
结果，当他去看约翰尼·德普的邮箱时，上面写着M.Schulman。所以那不是约翰尼·德普。我很惊讶迈克尔不认为那是化名。这是一个非常有趣的场景。我们拍了它，它还包括迈克尔对杰克·斯派洛的模仿。
That exists somewhere. You know, this is crazy. This is unlocking a memory for me when we read that at the table read. I thought that was so funny. Yeah. Amazing. Are we closing out the cold open?
那存在于某处。你知道，这太疯狂了，当我们读到剧本朗读时，这为我解锁了一个记忆。我觉得那太有趣了。是的。太棒了。我们要结束冷开场了吗？
That's it. We're done with the cold open. All right. Let's move in to the episode. Dwight goes up to Pam's desk and offers her a bagel. She doesn't want one because she's having an early lunch.
就这样。我们做完了冷开场。好了。让我们进入这一集。德怀特走到帕姆的桌子前，给她一个百吉饼。她不想要一个，因为她要吃早午餐。
And this is when we find out the information that she's going on this double date for her mom's birthday. We had a fan question from Genevieve B. in Omaha, Nebraska. Why is Pam wearing such neutral earthy colors in this episode? Normally, she would be wearing at least
这就是我们发现她要为她妈妈的生日去参加这个双重约会的信息的时候。我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州奥马哈的吉纳维芙·B的粉丝提问。为什么帕姆在这一集中穿着如此中性的大地色？通常，她至少会穿
a little pop of color, but in this episode, she looks like she's dressing, dare I say, like Dwight. What? I see what she's saying. The color palette is very shrewty. But I also noticed that everything about it
一点点亮色，但在这一集中，她看起来像是在打扮，我敢说，像德怀特。什么？我明白她在说什么。调色板非常像鼩鼱。但我也注意到关于它的一切
was there was no color. I think Pam is in mourning. I think she is going on this double date and she like when she looked in her closet, this is what spoke to her. I have noticed since Pam has become a salesman that her whole outfit has become more muted. There's less pop of color.
没有颜色。我认为帕姆在哀悼。我认为她要去参加这个双重约会，当她看她的衣柜时，这就是对她说话的东西。自从帕姆成为推销员以来，我注意到她的整套服装变得更加柔和。亮色更少了。
Yeah. I've noticed that too. We're going to get it back. Okay. Ryan is continuing to evolve. Who is Ryan? He's the hat wearing glasses guy. Now he's a photographer.
是的。我也注意到了。我们会把它拿回来的。好的。瑞安继续进化。瑞安是谁？他是那个戴眼镜戴帽子的家伙。现在他是摄影师。
He's showing his portfolio to Aaron. It's a black and white series that he calls exposure in the workplace. I wrote down the images I saw. Do tell. One looks like some drains on the side of the building. Another one is clearly the Dunder Mifflin parking lot.
他正在向艾琳展示他的作品集。这是一个黑白系列，他称之为工作场所的曝光。我写下了我看到的图像。说说看。一个看起来像建筑物侧面的排水管。另一个显然是邓德·米夫林的停车场。
You can see the top of Meredith's van, the hedge and the sign. And then of course we have Kelly Newdy from the waist up at her desk. We had a fan question from Cecilia P. in Minnesota who would like to know, what is this photo book? How did we take the photo of Mindy?
你可以看到梅雷迪思货车的顶部，树篱和标志。然后当然我们有凯利在桌子旁从腰部以上裸露。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州塞西莉亚·P的粉丝提问，她想知道，这本相册是什么？我们是怎么拍明迪的照片的？
I want to know everything. Let's hear it. Well, Randy Cordray told us that all of the photos were shot by our production designer, Michael Gallenberg. He would do that for the show. For example, you mentioned that coffee mug. Michael took the pictures of all the cast members that then Phil Shea put on the coffee mugs.
我想知道一切。让我们听听。好吧，兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，所有的照片都是由我们的制作设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格拍摄的。他会为节目做那个。例如，你提到了那个咖啡杯。迈克尔拍了所有演员的照片，然后菲尔·谢把它们放在咖啡杯上。
He's actually a very talented real life still photographer. So he did all of these photos. And the shoot with Mindy was done with her wearing like a flesh colored bandeau, like a tube top. Yes, because they knew that it would be pixelated later in post. So that's how we did it. You know, I'm going to bring out this story. I wasn't planning on it, but this episode feels like,
他实际上是一位非常有才华的现实生活静物摄影师。所以他拍了所有这些照片。和明迪的拍摄是她穿着像肉色的抹胸，像管状上衣。是的，因为他们知道它稍后会在后期像素化。所以这就是我们做的方式。你知道，我要讲这个故事。我没计划讲它，但这一集感觉，
I don't know, it feels like it would be on theme. I wrote about this in my book, The Actor's Life, A Survival Guide. The scene with Ryan showing Erin the pictures of like Kelly nude. Uh-huh. Have I ever told you the story of how I almost joined like an international Spice Girls singing group that was actually a front for a call girl service?
我不知道，感觉它会在主题上。我在我的书《演员的生活，生存指南》中写过这个。瑞安向艾琳展示凯利裸体照片的场景。嗯。我有没有告诉过你我差点加入一个国际辣妹合唱团的故事，那实际上是一个应召女郎服务的幌子？
What? Yeah. You thought you were auditioning to be in a band? Yeah. A singing group. That's how they hoodwinked the girls? Yeah. Yeah.
什么？是的。你以为你在试镜加入一个乐队？是的。一个歌唱团体。他们就是这样欺骗女孩的？是的。是的。
I've also told this story on Conan. Oh my gosh. So I moved to LA, and you know, you're just looking for any gig you can get. Sure. My friend was a really talented singer, and she saw a listing in the newspaper, the free newspaper. Okay, red flag number one.
我也在柯南节目上讲过这个故事。天哪。所以我搬到了洛杉矶，你知道，你只是在寻找你能得到的任何演出。当然。我的朋友是一位非常有才华的歌手，她在报纸上看到了一个列表，免费报纸。好的，红旗一号。
Correct. For singing auditions for a new international Spice Girls type singing band in this guy's condo. Red flag number two. Yeah, audition in a condo, red flag two. She asked if I would go with her. I said, sure, I'll go with you. So I stood in line with her, big group of people, went in,
正确。在这个家伙的公寓里为一个新的国际辣妹类型的歌唱乐队进行歌唱试镜。红旗二号。是的，在公寓里试镜，红旗二号。她问我是否愿意和她一起去。我说，当然，我会和你一起去。所以我排队和她在一起，一大群人，进去了，
sang, and the guy's like, do you sing? To me. And I'm like, not really. No. He's like, well, just sing something. So I sang Rocky Top. What? You know the song Rocky Top?
唱了，那个家伙说，你会唱歌吗？对我。我说，不完全是。不。他说，好吧，随便唱点什么。所以我唱了《Rocky Top》。什么？你知道《Rocky Top》这首歌吗？
Like, good old Rocky Top. Rocky Top, Tennessee. That's what came to your... That's what came to my mind. So I sang Rocky Top. Guess what, lady? You got the part. You're in the band.
就像，古老的《Rocky Top》。《Rocky Top》，田纳西。那就是出现在你的……那就是出现在我脑海里的。所以我唱了《Rocky Top》。你猜怎么着，女士？你得到了这个角色。你在乐队里。
I got it. With your Rocky Top song. I'm the American girl. Red flag number three. I get a call. It's me. Imagine my friend. My friend who's like a professional level singer.
我得到了它。用你的《Rocky Top》歌。我是美国女孩。红旗三号。我接到了一个电话。是我。想象一下我的朋友。我的朋友，她是一个专业水平的歌手。
Yeah. She didn't get the gig. I got it. I'm going to be the American girl. This guy gives me a tape. I'm supposed to listen to it. I'm supposed to learn my song. It was a country song about a truck stop.
是的。她没得到演出。我得到了。我要成为美国女孩。这个家伙给了我一盘磁带。我应该听它。我应该学习我的歌。那是一首关于卡车停靠站的乡村歌曲。
I practiced it and practiced it and practiced it. And I was like, when do I meet the other girls in the group? He's like soon, soon. Red flag. And then he calls me and he's like, listen, we have a gig coming up. I'm like, we have a gig coming up. I've never met the other girls in the group. How are we going to do our dance moves?
我练习了它，练习了它，练习了它。我说，我什么时候能见到组里的其他女孩？他说很快，很快。红旗。然后他给我打电话，他说，听着，我们有一个演出要来了。我说，我们有一个演出要来了。我从来没见过组里的其他女孩。我们要怎么做我们的舞蹈动作？
How are we going to harmonize? What are our outfits? And he's like, come by the condo. Red flag. And, you know, let me just see how your song is doing. You'll just do your song. You'll do it just a solo. I'm like, oh my gosh.
我们要怎么和谐？我们的服装是什么？他说，来公寓。红旗。而且，你知道，让我看看你的歌怎么样。你只会做你的歌。你只会做一个独唱。我说，天哪。
Okay. Meanwhile, by the way, I've basically told everyone back in Missouri, buckle in. I'm about to be a big star. A huge pop star. Oh my God. So just, I don't know if I'm going to be able to come home for Thanksgiving this year. I sang Rocky Top. I am now going to be a pop star.
好的。顺便说一句，我基本上告诉了密苏里州的每个人，系好安全带。我快要成为大明星了。一个巨大的流行歌星。天哪。所以只是，我不知道我今年感恩节是否能回家。我唱了《Rocky Top》。我现在要成为流行歌星了。
I had a whole new country name star for myself, Ginny Lee. My name was going to be Ginny Lee. Oh my God. You are giving me about my journal about like getting tooted at a party. You're Ginny Lee singing Rocky Top. I am. I'm part of the guys condo. And I've got my whole bit.
我为自己取了一个全新的乡村名字明星，吉妮·李。我的名字将是吉妮·李。天哪。你正在给我关于我的日记，关于在派对上被辅导。你是唱《Rocky Top》的吉妮·李。我是。我是那个家伙公寓的一部分。我有我的整个片段。
I just want to say that when I got there, there were girls walking around in lingerie. You guys, none of this is penetrating the stars in my eyes. None of this is like, I'm taking in none of this information. So I sing the song so earnestly. My truck stop song, gosh, I wish I still had the tape. And I'm like, oh, what do you think? You sang your country and Western song about a truck stop. Yeah.
我只想说，当我到那里时，有女孩穿着内衣走来走去。伙计们，这些都没有穿透我眼中的星星。这些都没有像，我没有吸收任何这些信息。所以我非常认真地唱了这首歌。我的卡车停靠站歌，天哪，我希望我还有那盘磁带。我说，哦，你觉得怎么样？你唱了你的乡村和西部歌曲关于卡车停靠站。是的。
Okay. I'm like, do you think I'm ready? He's like, I do, I do. Then he says to me, you know what you need are some lingerie. Well, I guess I skipped the part where he offered to take my photo. He had mentioned that my headshots, they weren't very dazzling. And he said that he takes headshots and he offered to take some new headshots for me. And I said, I can't afford that.
好的。我说，你觉得我准备好了吗？他说，我做，我做。然后他对我说，你知道你需要的是一些内衣。好吧，我想我跳过了他提出给我拍照的部分。他提到我的头像，它们不是很耀眼。他说他拍头像，他提出给我拍一些新的头像。我说，我负担不起。
He said, it's fine. You can pay me back later. And then he said, while we're doing it, why don't we take some of you in like a bikini or maybe nude? Because I'd like to represent you as an actress as well. And what if you go in on a part that requires nudity? You know, you don't want to have to get nude in the room. It'd be better to just hand them a photo. Which never happens.
他说，没关系。你可以以后再付钱给我。然后他说，当我们做的时候，为什么我们不拍一些你穿着比基尼或者裸体的照片？因为我也想作为演员代表你。如果你去参加一个需要裸体的角色怎么办？你知道，你不想在房间里裸体。最好直接给他们一张照片。这从来没发生过。
Never happens. Red flag. But you know what my answer was? What? I was like, you know what? I'm not going to want to do parts with nudity, so I won't need those photos. Again, why am I impenetrable? You're just sweet and innocent.
从来没发生过。红旗。但你知道我的回答是什么吗？什么？我说，你知道吗？我不会想做有裸体的角色，所以我不需要那些照片。再次，为什么我无法穿透？你只是甜美和天真。
And this person is a monster. OK, so what happened after you danced and sang your heart out about the truck stop? I said, am I ready? Do you think I should do the show on Friday? I'm so nervous. And he goes, I think you should. He goes, now here's the thing I also want you to know. It's going to be for a group of international businessmen.
而这个人是个怪物。好的，那么在你跳舞并唱出你关于卡车停靠站的心声后发生了什么？我说，我准备好了吗？你觉得我应该在周五做这个节目吗？我很紧张。他说，我觉得你应该。他说，现在这是我也想让你知道的事情。这将是一群国际商人。
Oh, gosh. It's a private show. And afterwards, you know, if you want to offer the gentleman some companionship, it can be quite lucrative. Here we go. This is when suddenly everything comes into focus for me. Suddenly I'm very aware of the people in lingerie. I'm very aware of the fact that I've never rehearsed with any of the other girls that offered to take nude photographs. The fact that my friend, who's an actual talented singer, didn't get the gig.
哦，天哪。这是一个私人表演。之后，你知道，如果你想给绅士们提供一些陪伴，那可能非常有利可图。我们开始吧。这就是突然一切对我来说都变得清晰的时候。突然我非常意识到穿着内衣的人。我非常意识到我从来没有和任何其他女孩排练过，提出拍裸体照片。我的朋友，一个真正有才华的歌手，没有得到演出的事实。
I'm like, oh my God, this is a call girl ring. I'm not going to be a famous pop star. And I left. I changed my phone numbers. I never spoke to him again. What did you tell everyone back in Missouri? The truth. You did.
我说，天哪，这是一个应召女郎团伙。我不会成为著名的流行歌星。我离开了。我换了电话号码。我再也没和他说过话。你告诉密苏里州的每个人什么了？真相。你做了。
I just did. I mean, what am I going to do? I told my parents. Were they like, get on a plane home? How did my parents not fly out and bring me home? I don't know. That was a very long tangent. But it sprung to mind when Ryan was like, I could take photos of you.
我只是做了。我的意思是，我要做什么？我告诉了我的父母。他们是不是说，坐飞机回家？我的父母怎么没有飞出来带我回家？我不知道。那是一个非常长的切线。但当瑞安说，我可以给你拍照时，它出现在脑海里。
Creeper. Creeper. So guys, if you're an aspiring actor and you want to come to Los Angeles or New York, maybe buy my book, The Actor's Life of Survival Guide, where I lay out a lot of things that you should and shouldn't do based on my experience. While this photo display is happening, Pam's mom walks in. Yes. And we're going to have a little bit of angel assess coming up. Oh yeah.
爬行者。爬行者。所以伙计们，如果你是一个有抱负的演员，你想来洛杉矶或纽约，也许买我的书，《演员的生活生存指南》，我在那里根据我的经验列出了很多你应该和不应该做的事情。当这个照片展示发生时，帕姆的妈妈进来了。是的。我们即将有一点安吉拉评估。哦，是的。
Pam, aren't you going to introduce us to Michael's girlfriend? Angela Martin enjoyed saying that so much. I know. How about the story about the necklace that Michael slipped onto Helene's neck this morning? Well, she was sleeping. Kelly's like, it's beautiful. No, it's not. I loved that.
帕姆，你不打算把我们介绍给迈克尔的女朋友吗？安吉拉·马丁非常喜欢说那个。我知道。迈克尔今天早上滑到海琳脖子上的项链的故事怎么样？好吧，她正在睡觉。凯利说，它很漂亮。不，它不是。我喜欢那个。
I'm going to break down all the gifts that Helene got in a little bit. Oh. So remember the necklace. We got a piece of mail from Genevieve B. in Omaha, Nebraska. Who said this? I found this fascinating. I worked as a manager for Claire's in the late aughts early 2010s, and I am 90% sure that Helene's necklace was from the icing's dressy special occasion collection. Claire's boutique in the mall?
我稍后会分解海琳得到的所有礼物。哦。所以记得项链。我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州奥马哈的吉纳维芙·B的一封邮件。谁说了这个？我觉得这很迷人。我在2000年代末2010年代初担任Claire's的经理，我有90%的把握海琳的项链来自icing的盛装特殊场合系列。商场里的Claire's精品店？
Yeah. That's where I got my ears pierced. Me too. Really? Yeah. Oh my gosh. It's still where you get your ears pierced. Yeah.
是啊。我就是在那里穿的耳洞。我也是。真的吗？是啊。天哪。那里现在还是穿耳洞的地方。是啊。
It's what they're known for. Genevieve goes on to say, if so, the piece in question appears to be a cubic zirconia necklace. And in 2009, 2010-ish, they were marked down to $5. Okay. I'm not sure where we got this necklace, but I think this is a good guess. I think it's a great catch. Well, Pam's going to try to get out of going to lunch by having Aaron transfer a fakey phone call. This was very funny to me, along with Creed's talking head.
那是他们的招牌。吉纳维芙接着说，如果是这样的话，那件首饰看起来是一条立方氧化锆项链。在2009年、2010年左右，它们降价到了5美元。好吧。我不确定我们是从哪里弄到这条项链的，但我认为这是一个很好的猜测。我觉得这是一个很棒的发现。好吧，帕姆打算让亚伦转接一个假电话来逃避午餐。这对我来说非常有趣，还有克里德的采访片段。
I thought all of it was really funny. I also loved John's performances, Jim, where he's like, nope, hardly ever. He like hangs up. Also, he doesn't say anything. Like when he's like, I'll handle it, he takes the phone, he goes, okay, great. Yeah. It's there. They found it.
我觉得这一切都非常有趣。我也很喜欢约翰的表演，吉姆，他那种“不，几乎没有”的样子。他就像挂断了电话。而且，他什么也没说。就像他说“我会处理的”，他接过电话，他说，好的，太棒了。是啊。它在那儿。他们找到了。
And then Creed's worried. He's like, that paper was never supposed to arrive. What is Creed running on the side? I don't know. Is Creed the reason they're going bankrupt? I think so. Probably. Pam doesn't get out of it.
然后克里德很担心。他说，那份文件根本就不该送达。克里德在私下里搞什么名堂？我不知道。克里德是他们破产的原因吗？我想是的。大概吧。帕姆没能逃掉。
She's got to go to this birthday double date. The car ride was so cringy, but guess what? The car ride home is going to be even worse. Pam's mom calls her Pammy. Did you notice? I did notice. And it's like Colleen and Michael are like talking to Pam about making good choices and being a good salesperson and they're being so parental.
她得去参加这个生日双重约会。车程太尴尬了，但你猜怎么着？回家的车程会更糟糕。帕姆的妈妈叫她帕米。你注意到了吗？我注意到了。就像科琳和迈克尔在和帕姆谈论做出正确的选择和做一个好的销售员，他们表现得太像家长了。
And you can just see like Pam was like, oh my God, what is happening? So next we're going to go into the kitchen and Dwight is continuing his favors for the office. He's cleaning out the freezer. Oh, I have some catches here. Oh, tell. Four minutes, 42 seconds. Did you guys see what all Dwight had taken out of the freezer and put on the counter?
你可以看出帕姆当时想的是，天哪，这到底是怎么回事？接下来我们要去厨房，德怀特正在继续为办公室做他的那些人情。他正在清理冰箱。哦，我这里有一些发现。哦，快说。4分42秒。你们看到德怀特从冰箱里拿出来放在台面上的所有东西了吗？
I did. I paused it. Took a screen grab. Let's see if we clocked the same stuff. Seven tubs of ice cream. Seven tubs of ice cream, all of which still have the plastic thing on them like none of them have been opened. Yeah.
我看到了。我暂停了。截了图。看看我们记下的东西是否一样。七桶冰淇淋。七桶冰淇淋，上面都还有塑料封条，好像都没开过。是啊。
Six frozen microwave dinners. Mm-hmm. Some mixed veggies. Mm-hmm. A whole thing of butter. A bag of, what is that, six small baguettes? Yes. And then two enormous bags of what looks like to be raw chicken sitting on top of the microwave.
六份冷冻微波炉晚餐。嗯哼。一些混合蔬菜。嗯哼。一整块黄油。一袋，那是什么，六个小法棍？是的。然后还有两袋巨大的看起来像是生鸡肉的东西放在微波炉上面。
Which we'll get called back later. So much raw chicken. We had a fan question from Hepsy from Cornavaca, Mexico. I noticed Dwight cleaning the fridge in this scene and I'm wondering if you guys ever used the fridge or freezer or cabinets to actually store your real snacks. We did not. It was just props. We never ate any of that.
这在后面会有呼应。太多的生鸡肉了。我们有一个来自墨西哥库埃纳瓦卡的赫普西的粉丝提问。我注意到德怀特在这一幕中清理冰箱，我想知道你们是否真的用过冰箱、冷冻柜或橱柜来存放你们真正的零食。我们没有。那只是道具。我们从来没吃过那些东西。
We never kept our food in there. Well, what? Sometimes Mindy would eat prop food. We know this. Mindy and Ed were notorious for eating prop food. But we kept all of our snacks in our desk drawer. Yes. My perishable snacks we kept in the fridge that was backstage.
我们从来没把食物放在那里。好吧，什么？有时候明迪会吃道具食物。我们知道这一点。明迪和埃德以吃道具食物而闻名。但我们把所有的零食都放在办公桌抽屉里。是的。我的易腐零食放在后台的冰箱里。
Yeah. But I had like a bag of potato chips and a drawer. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Like gum. Yeah. But I would never, I would not trust eating something I found in that fridge. No.
是啊。但我抽屉里有一袋薯片。哦，是的。哦，是的。还有口香糖。是啊。但我绝不会，我不会信任并吃掉我在那个冰箱里找到的东西。不会。
Because maybe it was from like, who knows when. Oh yeah. Unless it was a new item made for that episode, the other stuff in there just sort of stayed. I remember one time a few of us, I don't know why, ate some of those cheese balls. Oh yeah. I was there. I was part of that. Yeah.
因为也许它已经放了，谁知道多久了。哦，是的。除非它是为那一集制作的新物品，否则里面的其他东西就一直放在那儿。我记得有一次我们几个人，不知道为什么，吃了一些那种奶酪球。哦，是的。我在场。我是其中之一。是啊。
It was like a dare near the end. All of a sudden I remember Phil shaking like, guys, guys, we spray those with the stuff so they don't go bad. We're like, ugh. Yeah. With like a lacquer. Well, you know, we're fine. We're here.
那是在快结束时的一个大冒险。突然我记得菲尔摇着头说，伙计们，伙计们，我们往那些东西上喷了药水，所以它们不会变质。我们当时想，呃。是啊。就像漆一样。好吧，你知道，我们没事。我们还在这儿。
Well, while Dwight's cleaning out the freezer, Andy comes in to give him his newly polished briefcase because he's returning the favor of the bagels. And this leads to this favor competition basically as they're walking back to their desks. It's really funny. These two guys cracked me up. Me too. You know, at five minutes 36 seconds, Dwight says, if you clench your buttocks together
好吧，当德怀特在清理冷冻柜时，安迪进来给他看他刚擦亮的公文包，因为他在回报百吉饼的人情。这导致了他们走回办公桌时的一场人情竞争。这真的很有趣。这两个家伙让我笑死了。我也是。你知道，在5分36秒时，德怀特说，如果你走路时把臀部夹紧，
while walking, you can really take the pressure off your knees. Little tip there. Just a little tip. Well, I looked it up. Does it work? I was going to try it. Well, I read an article called Getting to the Bottom of Knee Pain in Women. Ew.
你可以真正减轻膝盖的压力。一个小贴士。只是一个小贴士。好吧，我查了一下。它管用吗？我本来想试试。好吧，我读了一篇名为《深入了解女性膝盖疼痛》的文章。呃。
Okay. Knee pain in women. That's their butt's question mark, the article asks. It says, if you're experiencing knee pain and you go to a physical therapist, they might ask you, are you using your butt? If the pain is not from like an obvious injury, you know, this physical therapist says I always start with the glutes. I guess a lot of times knee pain can be caused by either tight, weak hips or weak glutes
好吧。女性膝盖疼痛。文章问，那是她们的屁股吗？它说，如果你正在经历膝盖疼痛并去看物理治疗师，他们可能会问你，你在用你的屁股吗？如果疼痛不是来自明显的损伤，你知道，这位物理治疗师说我总是从臀肌开始。我想很多时候膝盖疼痛可能是由紧绷、虚弱的髋部或虚弱的臀肌引起的，
because the glutes are like your stabilizer. And so they will often want you to increase your glutes, but the question here is if you're supposed to clench your buttocks or not when you walk. And so while yes, weak glutes could be the root of your knee problem, I read a different article called To Clench or Not to Clench Your Butt. That is the question by Brooke Thomas. She says, do not permaclench your butt. Don't permaclench it.
因为臀肌就像你的稳定器。所以他们通常会希望你加强臀肌，但这里的问题是你走路时是否应该夹紧臀部。所以虽然是的，虚弱的臀肌可能是你膝盖问题的根源，但我读了另一篇名为《夹紧还是不夹紧你的屁股》的文章。这是布鲁克·托马斯提出的问题。她说，不要永久夹紧你的屁股。不要永久夹紧它。
What's a permaclench? That's I think where you're just clenching for no reason. Why would you clench for no reason? To take the pressure off your knees. She said it can lead to other problems. It can lead to wear and tear on your lumbar discs. You can get too tight of a pelvic floor. I guess that's bad.
什么是永久夹紧？我想那是你无缘无故地夹紧。为什么要无缘无故地夹紧？为了减轻膝盖的压力。她说这会导致其他问题。它会导致腰椎间盘的磨损。你的盆底肌会变得太紧。我想那很糟糕。
Instead of clenching, just do good glute workouts to build up the whole muscle. Okay. Okay. I know that we have not gotten very far into this episode, but should we take a break though and then we'll come back and we'll break down the rest? Yeah, because when we come back, the Scott family is checking in at the restaurant. Yes. Scott family table is ready.
与其夹紧，不如做好的臀部锻炼来增强整个肌肉。好吧。好吧。我知道我们还没看完这一集，但我们应该休息一下，然后再回来分析剩下的部分吗？好的，因为当我们回来时，斯科特一家正在餐厅办理入住。是的。斯科特一家的桌子准备好了。
But which one is it? I mean, there's just a bunch of boring tables. Yeah. Oh, wait. One has a ton of balloons and nice of the restaurant to let them hang a banner in their potted plants. I know. It is so sweet.
但到底是哪一张？我的意思是，只是一堆无聊的桌子。是啊。哦，等等。一张桌子上有大量的气球，餐厅让他们在盆栽植物上挂横幅真是太好了。我知道。这太贴心了。
Michael has completely decorated this table for Helene's birthday. Pam notices. I think this is the first moment where she's kind of softening to this. Also because Helene is so delighted. She's so happy. They start the birthday lunch sort of talking about how like, oh, they're at this great Italian restaurant. Michael's like, you know, I'd love to go to Italy.
迈克尔已经为海琳的生日把这张桌子装饰得面目全非。帕姆注意到了。我认为这是她开始对这件事有点软化的第一个时刻。也因为海琳非常高兴。她太开心了。他们开始生日午餐，谈论着，哦，他们在一家很棒的意大利餐厅。迈克尔说，你知道，我很想去意大利。
Helene's like, oh, you can have all my travel books. I, you know, I can't do those big trips anymore. Yeah, the flights are too long. Yeah. Not interested. And he's like, great, I guess I'll take your books. And then Pam and her mom have this like fun little banter. Pam's like, so mom, which birthday are we celebrating this year?
海琳说，哦，你可以拿走我所有的旅游书。我，你知道，我不能再进行那些长途旅行了。是啊，飞行时间太长了。是啊。不感兴趣。他说，太好了，我想我会拿走你的书。然后帕姆和她妈妈有这种有趣的调侃。帕姆说，那么妈妈，我们今年庆祝的是几岁生日？
Jenna, I used to do this with my mom. What do you mean? I would be like, okay, mom, what birthday is it? And for years, my mom said 32. Really? 32. That is so funny. So Helene says, I'm sticking with 49.
珍娜，我过去常和我妈妈这样。你是什么意思？我会说，好吧，妈妈，这是几岁生日？多年来，我妈妈都说32岁。真的吗？32岁。这太搞笑了。所以海琳说，我坚持说49岁。
Pam says 49 again. That's nine years in a row. Michael's like, haha, that's funny, but you can see him trying to do the math. But then he's going to need to take pencil to paper. And still get it wrong. Right. Michael realizes that Helene is 58. And you can tell this hits him pretty hard.
帕姆说又是49岁。那是连续九年了。迈克尔说，哈哈，那很有趣，但你可以看到他在试图做数学题。但他需要拿笔和纸。而且还是算错了。对。迈克尔意识到海琳58岁了。你可以看出这对他的打击很大。
We had a fan catch, though, from Allison H. and Louisville, Kentucky, and many others, by the way, who said, I think there's a math error. Helene says she's 49. Pam says it's the ninth year in a row. But if she first celebrated her 49th birthday on her 49th birthday, that counts as one of the nine. So you would actually add 49 plus eight additional birthdays, which means Helene is really turning 57.
不过，我们收到了来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的艾莉森·H以及许多其他人的粉丝发现，他们说，我认为有一个数学错误。海琳说她49岁。帕姆说这是连续第九年了。但如果她第一次在49岁生日时庆祝她的49岁生日，那算作九年中的一年。所以你实际上应该加上49岁加上额外的八个生日，这意味着海琳实际上是57岁。
Nice catch. Yeah. So when I was trading messages with Charlie Grandy about this episode, he said that what he remembers most about working with Seth Gordon was the fact that me, John, Steve, and Linda were going to be locked at this same table for like four big scenes in a row. And it became this big question, how are we going to visually differentiate these scenes? How are we going to make them feel alive? Right.
好发现。是啊。所以当我和查理·格兰迪交流这一集时，他说他关于与塞斯·戈登合作最难忘的是，我和约翰、史蒂夫、琳达要被锁在同一张桌子上，连续拍四场大戏。这成了一个大问题，我们该如何从视觉上区分这些场景？我们该如何让它们看起来生动？对。
And Charlie said, if you rewatch it, you can really see what a great job he did. He added multiple angles. He keeps flipping sides to keep it interesting. And by mostly framing out the other tables, he does a great job of shrinking what was a really big space and, quote, imprisoning you in Michael's awkwardness. Ooh, that's so artsy. I know. And it's really true.
查理说，如果你重看一遍，你真的能看出他做得有多棒。他增加了多个角度。他不断翻转侧面以保持趣味性。通过主要遮挡其他桌子，他很好地缩小了原本很大的空间，并“囚禁”在迈克尔的尴尬中。哦，那太有艺术感了。我知道。而且确实如此。
I started rewatching these scenes and we only used two cameras, but in each of the scenes, they set them up a little differently. So you didn't feel like you were coming back to the same table. And as the scenes go on, the camera gets closer and closer and closer. So you really are like going into Michael's like little mind. It's cool. It's really cool. Well, we're going to go from this talk of being 49, nine years in a row, but actually
我开始重看这些场景，我们只用了两台摄像机，但在每一场戏中，他们的设置都略有不同。所以你不会觉得你又回到了同一张桌子。随着场景的进行，摄像机越来越近。所以你真的就像进入了迈克尔的小脑袋。很酷。真的很酷。好吧，我们要从谈论连续九年49岁，但实际上
being 58 with more sexy talk. What nameshow should be called, Nana or Grandma? Michael's really feeling it now. He is. I noticed something at nine minutes and six seconds in the scene. What? Do you notice how Steve eats his food as Michael Scott? It's exactly how he ate in dinner party.
是58岁，转到更多性感的话题。应该叫什么名字，娜娜还是奶奶？迈克尔现在真的很有感觉。他是。我在9分06秒的场景中注意到了一些事情。什么？你注意到史蒂夫作为迈克尔·斯科特是怎么吃东西的吗？这和他吃晚餐派对时一模一样。
So he kind of scrapes the fork with his teeth. Yes. He eats tiny amounts of food off the tip of the fork with his very front teeth. He doesn't put the fork all the way in his mouth. He like bites it off the tip of the fork. It's very interesting. He does not eat this way in real life. I've dined with him many times.
他用牙齿刮叉子。是的。他用门牙从叉尖上吃极少量的食物。他没有把叉子完全放进嘴里。他就像从叉尖上咬下来。这很有趣。他在现实生活中不是这样吃东西的。我和他一起吃过很多次饭。
This is clearly a Michael Scott eating choice. It's either a Michael Scott eating choice or it's Steve the actor not wanting to eat the prop food and making the best of it. Because I would do something similar. I would just put the tiniest amount on the end of the fork or spoon so I didn't have to eat too much of it. Well, now I guess I'd have to watch Steve's other films and see if he's eating in any of them and see if this is just his actor way of eating or if it was a character choice.
这显然是迈克尔·斯科特的进食选择。这要么是迈克尔·斯科特的进食选择，要么是演员史蒂夫不想吃道具食物，并尽量利用它。因为我会做类似的事情。我只会把极少量放在叉子或勺子的末端，这样我就不必吃太多。好吧，现在我想我得看看史蒂夫的其他电影，看看他是否在其中吃东西，看看这只是他演员的进食方式，还是一个角色选择。
I'll investigate. I'll investigate because with prop food, when you start out, it's usually really fresh and warm and they've made it ready for you to eat, but as each take goes, it gets colder and colder and a little bit more willty depending what you're eating and I just found early on the smaller bites are better. True. It's also lunchtime back at Dunder Mifflin and oh my gosh, Andy has set up a whole taco buffet in the conference room.
我会调查的。我会调查的，因为对于道具食物，当你开始时，它通常非常新鲜和温暖，他们已经准备好让你吃了，但随着每一条拍摄，它变得越来越冷，根据你吃的东西，变得有点枯萎，我发现早点吃小口更好。真的。邓德·米夫林那边也是午餐时间，天哪，安迪在会议室里布置了一个完整的塔可自助餐。
Yes, but Dwight is going to volunteer to serve everyone. Yes. Did you notice at nine minutes, 26 seconds when Angela Martin enters? Yes. Her face she makes and she does a 180 out of the room. Well, because she's vegetarian. So I went to the script because I was like, what did it say in the script about this moment?
是的，但德怀特会自愿为每个人服务。是的。你在9分26秒安吉拉·马丁进来时注意到了吗？是的。她做的表情，然后她180度转弯离开了房间。好吧，因为她是素食主义者。所以我查了剧本，因为我想，剧本里关于这一刻是怎么说的？
In the script, it just says Angela Martin enters the room and immediately walks back out. Oh, so the face I made was just me, like probably playing around in the moment. I have a question. Did you guys actually eat those tacos that day? They looked good. We did not just because it had to sit there for a bit, but we wanted to when they first brought them out, we're like, whoa, tacos and like, no, no, no guys.
在剧本里，它只是说安吉拉·马丁走进房间，然后立即走出去。哦，所以我做的表情只是我，可能是在那一刻玩闹。我有一个问题。你们那天真的吃了那些塔可吗？它们看起来不错。我们没有，只是因为它们必须在那儿放一会儿，但当他们刚拿出来时我们想吃，我们当时想，哇，塔可，然后，不，不，不，伙计们。
There's also a Kevin talking head and little moment that got deleted probably for time. I loved it. Kevin is so excited that Dwight is going to serve the tacos and he has this talking head. This is great. I love tacos. Whenever I try to make one, I get too excited and I crush it. And so then it cuts back to the scene and Dwight's making his taco, Dwight hands it
还有一个凯文的采访片段和被删掉的小片段，可能是因为时间原因。我很喜欢它。凯文非常兴奋德怀特要供应塔可，他有这个采访片段。这太棒了。我喜欢塔可。每当我尝试做一个时，我太兴奋了，我把它捏碎了。所以它切回场景，德怀特正在做他的塔可，德怀特把它递给
to Kevin and Kevin's so excited he crushes it in his hand. Kevin. Well, after these guys compete to see who's going to serve the tacos, now they're going to compete to see who's going to clean them up. It doesn't stop. It doesn't stop. Jen, I'd like to break down all the gifts that Michael got, Helene. And really show how all out he went for her until he broke up with her.
凯文，凯文太兴奋了，他在手里把它捏碎了。凯文。好吧，在这些人竞争谁来供应塔可之后，现在他们要竞争谁来清理它们。没完没了。没完没了。珍，我想分析一下迈克尔送给海琳的所有礼物。并真正展示他在和她分手前是多么全力以赴。
He went all out. He got her the necklace and then also the lunch reservation, right? Where he decorated the table, I counted eight balloons, a birthday banner, and also a really beautiful flower arrangement that none of the other tables had. Yes. I assume she can take that with her. Yes. As well as a scrapbook of their courtship, the wrapping paper says love in several different
他全力以赴。他送了她项链，还有午餐预订，对吧？他装饰了桌子，我数了八个气球，一个生日横幅，还有一束非常漂亮的花，其他桌子都没有。是的。我假设她可以把它带走。是的。还有一本他们求爱的剪贴簿，包装纸上用几种不同的语言写着爱。
languages. Here are a few things that were in the scrapbook. Per the shooting draft, some made it in the episode. Some did not. Oh. The penny that Helene threw into the wishing well at the mall. Which doesn't exist. Right.
以下是剪贴簿里的一些东西。根据拍摄草稿，有些出现在了剧集中。有些没有。哦。海琳扔进商场许愿池的那枚硬币。那根本不存在。对。
The fountain that doesn't exist. Also a ticket stub to a movie they went to together, Love Happens. Oh. I looked up Love Happens. It was a movie that was out in 2009 starring Jennifer Aniston and Aaron Eckhart. As well as the poem that Michael wrote slash plagiarized from Shel Silverstein. Here was the poem. I cannot go to school today, said little Peggy Ann McKay.
那个不存在的喷泉。还有他们一起去看的一部电影的票根，《爱发生》。哦。我查了《爱发生》。那是2009年上映的一部电影，由詹妮弗·安妮斯顿和艾伦·艾克哈特主演。还有迈克尔写给/抄袭自谢尔·希尔弗斯坦的诗。诗是这样的。我今天不能去学校了，小佩吉·安·麦凯说。
I have the measles and the mumps, a gash, a rash, and purple bumps. My teachers really mean happy birthday. I love you, Helene. I mean, it's beautiful. It might be in my journal. We had a fan question about the scrapbook from Carla B. in Gardena, California. The cover page of the scrapbook at the very bottom where it says Love Copyright Michael. We also see the letters XXLR.
我有麻疹和腮腺炎，一道伤口，皮疹，还有紫色肿块。我的老师真的很刻薄，生日快乐。我爱你，海琳。我的意思是，它很美。它可能在我的日记里。我们收到了一个关于剪贴簿的粉丝提问，来自加利福尼亚州加迪纳的卡拉·B。剪贴簿的封面页，最底部写着“爱 版权所有 迈克尔”。我们还看到了字母XXLR。
Any idea what those letters stand for? Do you know, Ange? I do. What is it? It's in the shooting draft. Oh, tell us. Because I thought they were Roman numerals, but when I looked it up, there's no R in Roman numerals.
知道这些字母代表什么吗？你知道吗，安吉？我知道。是什么？它在拍摄草稿里。哦，告诉我们。因为我以为它们是罗马数字，但当我查的时候，罗马数字里没有R。
Yes. So Helene reads that out loud, kind of like Curious, and Michael goes, those are Roman numerals. I made them up. Oh my gosh! I did not know that you knew the answer to that question when I asked it. Yeah, it's in the shooting draft. Oh, the shooting draft.
是的。所以海琳大声读出来，有点像好奇，迈克尔说，那是罗马数字。我编的。天哪！我问这个问题时，我不知道你知道答案。是啊，它在拍摄草稿里。哦，拍摄草稿。
It unlocks so many mysteries. So many mysteries. I have a few other things to share from the shooting draft as well. Did you notice that Jim and Pam left under Mifflin with a box, a gift box wrapped in green wrapping paper? Jim is carrying it. Oh, yes. Yes.
它解开了这么多谜团。这么多谜团。我还有一些其他事情要从拍摄草稿中分享。你注意到吉姆和帕姆带着一个用绿色包装纸包裹的礼品盒离开了邓德·米夫林吗？吉姆拿着它。哦，是的。是的。
Yes. And they bring it in to the restaurant. It's their gift to Helene. Oh! Do you know what they got? Helene? What? In the shooting draft, it says, Helene is holding a sweater that Jim and Pam gave her.
是的。他们把它带到了餐厅。这是他们送给海琳的礼物。哦！你知道他们送了什么吗？海琳？什么？在拍摄草稿里，它说，海琳拿着一件吉姆和帕姆送给她的毛衣。
Michael, oh, what a nice gift. Oh, yes, a cozy sweater on his 58-year-old girlfriend. It's not sexy. It's not sexy to him. I mean, Michael is really spiraling. So much so that he's going to go hide. Jim has to go find him. He's like hiding in the bar.
迈克尔，哦，多好的礼物。哦，是的，一件舒适的毛衣，送给他58岁的女朋友。这不性感。对他来说不性感。我的意思是，迈克尔真的失控了。以至于他要去躲起来。吉姆不得不去找他。他就像躲在酒吧里。
Yeah. She's like, come on, weirdo, it's time for cake. This scene was amazing. Start to finish. The fact that it starts off with Michael saying, finish your cake, Helene. I want you to enjoy that cake because I have something terrible I need to tell you. Yeah. How did you get through that without laughing?
是啊。她说，来吧，怪胎，是时候吃蛋糕了。这一幕太棒了。从头到尾。它以迈克尔说“吃完你的蛋糕，海琳”开始。我希望你享受那个蛋糕，因为我有件可怕的事情需要告诉你。是啊。你是怎么在不笑的情况下完成的？
First of all, the thing that made us laugh the most was the waitress interrupting us to pour the water. That was so brilliant. I thought that was brilliant. It is scripted exactly in the shooting draft the way you guys shot it. Yeah. Because this is what you really do. You have these conversations and sometimes someone walks up to your table and you have
首先，让我们笑得最厉害的是服务员打断我们倒水。那太精彩了。我觉得那很精彩。它在拍摄草稿中完全按照你们拍摄的方式写好了。是啊。因为这就是你真正做的。你有这些对话，有时有人走到你的桌子旁，你不得不
to stop mid-sentence. Yes. I do it all the time. All the time. What is that like from the waiter's point of view? I mean, you know, I walked in a restaurant, you know, people like you walk up. Sometimes you hear stuff. Sometimes they don't stop.
在半句话中停下来。是的。我经常这样做。一直都在做。从服务员的角度来看那是什么样的？我的意思是，你知道，我走进一家餐厅，你知道，像你这样的人走过来。有时你会听到一些东西。有时他们不停下来。
But this was hilarious. Michael is saying how he wants kids and you, any gestures to Helene, unfortunately have already completed that part of your journey down there. Pam's like, Michael, Michael's like, hey, it's not my decision. It's mother nature. Mother has very strict rules about fur, tilty. It was so difficult to get through. I would have completely lost it.
但这太搞笑了。迈克尔在说他想要孩子，你，任何手势对海琳，不幸的是，你已经在下面完成了那部分旅程。帕姆说，迈克尔，迈克尔说，嘿，这不是我的决定。这是大自然母亲。母亲对毛皮、倾斜度有非常严格的规定。太难完成了。我本来会完全失控的。
So Michael's clearly breaking up with Helene and he uses Pam as the excuse. He's like, you know, I've thought about it. This isn't fair to Pam. Pam's like, no, no, no, Michael, Jenna, there was a talking head that would have come here. It was in the shooting draft. It got deleted and it really showed what Pam was feeling. I'm going to read it to you. Okay.
所以迈克尔显然要和海琳分手，他用帕姆作为借口。他说，你知道，我想过了。这对帕姆不公平。帕姆说，不，不，不，迈克尔，珍娜，这里本来有一个采访片段。它在拍摄草稿里。它被删掉了，它真的展示了帕姆的感受。我要读给你听。好的。
My mom used to call me every night to cry about the divorce. Then she started dating Michael and she stopped calling. And I thought it was because she knew how mad I was, but now I think it was because she stopped crying. And that's what I should want for her, right? And so you would have had that talking head and then you would have cut back to the scene when Pam's like, you know what, no, Michael, it's, it's okay. It took me a while to come around to it, but I'm okay with it.
我妈妈过去每晚都打电话给我哭诉离婚的事。然后她开始和迈克尔约会，她就不再打电话了。我以为是因为她知道我有多生气，但现在我想是因为她不再哭了。而那才是我应该为她想要的，对吧？所以你本来会有那个采访片段，然后你会切回场景，当帕姆说，你知道吗，不，迈克尔，没关系。我花了一段时间才接受它，但我对此没问题。
I'm glad they cut that talking head because I think that makes you kind of really hate Michael for breaking up with her because I don't know. It's so, it's so pure. It's so sweet, you know, and it just really breaks your heart for Helene. Too much. Too much. Yes. Before we move on, I just want to say the cake was really good.
我很高兴他们删掉了那个采访片段，因为我认为这让你有点真的讨厌迈克尔和她分手，因为我不知道。它太，它太纯洁了。它太甜了，你知道，它真的让你的心为海琳碎了。太多了。太多了。是的。在我们继续之前，我只想说蛋糕真的很好吃。
Oh, I wondered about that. It brought back memories. Well, Michael's going to tell Helene there is another woman and her name is Italy and skydiving and bungee jumping. And then Jenna, Michael decides that he's going to also try to comfort her in this moment. It's in the deleted scenes. We have to hear it. It's like you don't buy a Mad Libs book with everything already written in it.
哦，我对此很好奇。它勾起了回忆。好吧，迈克尔要告诉海琳还有另一个女人，她的名字叫意大利，还有跳伞和蹦极。然后珍娜，迈克尔决定他也要在这一刻安慰她。它在删除的场景里。我们必须听听。就像你不会买一本所有内容都已经写好的疯狂填词书。
We're going to find somebody so quickly with your killer bod and your wisdom. Somebody kicked. Did you guys get kicked? Nope. I kicked you. Stop. Jim kicks Michael really hard. It is so funny.
我们会很快找到某人，带着你杀手的身材和你的智慧。有人踢了。你们被踢了吗？没有。我踢了你。停下。吉姆狠狠地踢了迈克尔。这太搞笑了。
And I think I almost see you start to break. I remember filming those now. It was really funny. Yeah. Michael is like, what, what? And Jim just shuts him down. And this leads us to the super cringy car right home. Yeah.
而且我想我几乎看到你开始崩溃了。我现在记得拍摄那些场景了。这真的很有趣。是啊。迈克尔说，什么，什么？吉姆只是让他闭嘴。这把我们带到了超级尴尬的回家车程。是啊。
Helene is wondering out loud, what is she going to do now? She's 58 and single. And Michael's like, how about hobbies? Jim's like, no, no. The scene continued on. Helene says, why do I keep dating these losers? But she doesn't stop there. We have to hear it.
海琳在想，她现在该怎么办？她58岁了，单身。迈克尔说，爱好怎么样？吉姆说，不，不。场景继续。海琳说，为什么我一直和这些失败者约会？但她没有停在那里。我们必须听听。
What is it about me that makes me choose these loser guys? I don't know if I'd say you want to stay. I'm totally choosing the station. Do you know how long it's been since I've had an orgasm? Years. She told me she doesn't like them. Oh my God. Isn't that so funny?
我身上有什么让我选择这些失败者男人的？我不知道我是否会说你想留下来。我完全选择了这个车站。你知道我有多久没有高潮了吗？几年了。她告诉我她不喜欢它们。天哪。那不是很有趣吗？
I mean, how awkward is that car ride for Pam? Oh my gosh. I mean, Pam has had to hear so much today. So much. Maybe she already knew. I mean, it sounds like they're close, but I don't know. I think there's new information coming up today. Oh yeah.
我的意思是，那次车程对帕姆来说有多尴尬？天哪。我的意思是，帕姆今天不得不听这么多。这么多。也许她已经知道了。我的意思是，听起来他们很亲近，但我不知道。我认为今天有新的信息出现。哦，是的。
Oh yeah. Well, they get back to the office. And first of all, we see Andy trying to get something from a real tall shelf. He can't get it. Dwight, can you help me? Dwight's so excited. Here it is.
哦，是的。好吧，他们回到办公室。首先，我们看到安迪试图从一个很高的架子上拿东西。他拿不到。德怀特，你能帮我吗？德怀特太兴奋了。在这儿。
Andy needs them. It's a favor. Guess what it is? Starbucks gift card. From everyone. Were you curious how Andy got the whole group to chip in for a gift card for Dwight? A little.
安迪需要它们。这是一个人情。你猜是什么？星巴克礼品卡。来自每个人。你好奇安迪是怎么让整个小组凑钱买一张给德怀特的礼品卡的吗？有点。
I was, so I went to the shooting draft. Does it tell all? It tells all. And I'm going to share it with you. Dwight goes to the restroom and when he does, Andy gets up and makes an announcement to the bullpen. He says, maybe you noticed Dwight has been trying real hard to do nice things for us.
我是，所以我去了拍摄草稿。它说明了一切吗？它说明了一切。我要和你分享。德怀特去洗手间，当他去的时候，安迪站起来向牛棚（办公区）宣布。他说，也许你们注意到德怀特一直在努力为我们做些好事。
That's not his normal way. And he's not having an easy time with it. And like the bullpen's like, who cares? Stanley's like, so Meredith's like, what's your game? Andy's like, we need to give him a gift. And Creed's like, what? Like a present? Andy continues.
那不是他通常的方式。而且他做起来并不容易。牛棚里的人就像，谁在乎？斯坦利说，所以梅雷迪思说，你的游戏是什么？安迪说，我们需要给他一份礼物。克里德说，什么？像礼物一样？安迪继续说。
And he says, Dwight wakes up every day at 4 a.m. and kills a pig. That's his workout. He's not like us. But today he tried. And you know, it wasn't too long ago, I had a temper. I was a real bastard. And do you know what got me out of it?
他说，德怀特每天凌晨4点起床，杀一头猪。那是他的锻炼。他不像我们。但今天他尝试了。而且你知道，不久前，我脾气暴躁。我真是个混蛋。你知道是什么让我摆脱了它吗？
Oscar comes in with some snark and says, mandatory anger management. We're calling back all this stuff. Yeah. And Andy goes, no. And he like wants to shout at Oscar so badly. And Ed is really funny in the scene. He goes, no, the kindness and gentle words of my anger
奥斯卡带着一些讽刺进来，说，强制性的愤怒管理。我们正在呼应所有这些东西。是啊。安迪说，不。他非常想对奥斯卡大喊大叫。埃德在这一幕里真的很有趣。他说，不，我愤怒管理赞助人的善良和温柔的话语。
management sponsor. And his whole thing is, guys, my point is, maybe we can be that for Dwight. We can be that person. Wow. And Phyllis coming in hard with the sass says, look, we all do nice things. I bring in muffins at least once a week.
他的整个观点是，伙计们，我的意思是，也许我们可以成为德怀特的那个。我们可以成为那个人。哇。菲利斯带着刻薄进来，说，看，我们都做过好事。我至少每周带一次松饼。
And Stanley says, those are leftover book group muffins. Oh my gosh. There's so much sass. Anyway, Andy's like, hey, we're getting off topic. He's coming back. Will you guys please give me some money? So when Dwight gets the gift card and it pans to the bullpen, do you see how like everyone is like, whatever.
斯坦利说，那是剩下的读书小组松饼。天哪。有太多的刻薄。总之，安迪说，嘿，我们偏离主题了。他要回来了。你们能给我一些钱吗？所以当德怀特拿到礼品卡，镜头转向牛棚时，你看到每个人都像，随便吧。
Yeah, that's why. Wow. The shooting draft. The shooting draft. Well, Michael is going to ask Pam to come in his office. It's about work. It really is. It is about work.
是啊，这就是原因。哇。拍摄草稿。拍摄草稿。好吧，迈克尔要让帕姆进他的办公室。是关于工作的。确实是关于工作的。
It is. He is going to offer her a raise. She's going to take it. Yeah. But it's still not changing her mood towards him. No. And he wants her to know that the raise has strings attached from his heart to her mean attitude.
是的。他要给她加薪。她会接受的。是啊。但这仍然没有改变她对他的态度。不。他想让她知道，加薪是有附加条件的，从他的心到她刻薄的态度。
Pam's like, are you bribing me? And then he's like, well, what do you want? What do you want? Do you want a million dollars? Do you want to hit me? She says, I want to hit you. Lady, this plot line was so controversial. When this ended up airing, oh my gosh, it lit up the message boards.
帕姆说，你在贿赂我吗？然后他说，好吧，你想要什么？你想要什么？你想要一百万美元吗？你想打我吗？她说，我想打你。女士，这个情节太有争议了。当它播出时，天哪，它点燃了留言板。
I bet not only does she want to hit him, but she says in the parking lot in front of everyone, I'm going to hit you as hard as I can. Everyone gets very invested very quickly. There's a lot of chatter around the office. And Toby is like, Pam, can I talk to you for a second? We all think he's human resources and he's going to stop this. Yes.
我敢打赌，她不仅想打他，而且她在停车场当着所有人的面说，我要尽可能用力地打你。每个人都很快投入其中。办公室周围有很多闲聊。托比说，帕姆，我能和你谈谈吗？我们都以为他是人力资源部，他会阻止这一切。是的。
But Toby just wants to confirm that she'll be hitting him off property. And then he wants to show her how to throw a punch. Oh my gosh. Charlie Grandi said that Paul is the one who pitched this bit. He pitched it in the room during the rewrite. And Charlie said he was pretty new on the office at this time. And when Paul was first pitching it, he thought, well, I don't know. How is this going to play realistically and funny?
但托比只是想确认她会在公司外打他。然后他想教她怎么出拳。天哪。查理·格兰迪说，保罗是提出这个点子的人。他在重写期间在房间里提出了它。查理说他当时在办公室还很新。当保罗第一次提出它时，他想，好吧，我不知道。这怎么能演得既现实又有趣呢？
But Paul was like, I know how to do it. I know how to do it. And he said that Paul just did it perfectly. Totally. I also think this whole joke of Toby showing Pam how to throw a punch is a great example of a joke that lives in history in the character. This is part of Toby's history. And we have gotten to know Toby so well.
但保罗说，我知道怎么做。我知道怎么做。他说保罗做得非常完美。完全正确。我也认为托比教帕姆出拳的整个笑话是历史上存在于角色中的笑话的一个很好的例子。这是托比历史的一部分。我们已经非常了解托比了。
And we have seen years of Michael giving Toby, you know, such a hard time that of course, of course, Toby's going to be like, so the power comes from your back foot when you want to turn. Because it's so clear, the joke is in the subtext that Toby has fantasized about throwing a punch at Michael for years. We had a fan catch from Efrat T in Israel who just wanted to point out that when Michael hit Meredith with this car, he tells Ryan that it was on company grounds because it was the parking lot.
我们已经看到了迈克尔多年来给托比（你知道）这么大的压力，所以当然，当然，托比会说，所以力量来自你的后脚，当你想要转身时。因为很清楚，笑话的潜台词是托比多年来一直幻想给迈克尔一拳。我们收到了来自以色列的埃弗拉特·T的粉丝发现，他只是想指出，当迈克尔用这辆车撞到梅雷迪思时，他告诉瑞安，那是在公司场地，因为那是停车场。
Oh, good catch. But also in the duel, Andy and Dwight are fighting in the parking lot and Jim tells them not to fight at work. So just kind of pointing out, suddenly the parking lot is not company property, at least as far as Toby is concerned. That is a really good catch because technically, she'd have to try to throw a punch out in the street. Or at least on the sidewalk.
哦，好发现。但同样在决斗中，安迪和德怀特在停车场打架，吉姆告诉他们不要在工作时打架。所以只是指出，突然停车场不是公司财产，至少就托比而言是这样。这是一个非常好的发现，因为从技术上讲，她必须尝试在街上出拳。或者至少在人行道上。
Yeah. Well, speaking of the parking lot, everyone's gathered outside. Kevin's money is on Pam. Oscar notes it's a one-sided fight. It's not really, you know, Pam winning is the only outcome here. Well, right now there's no Michael. There's just Pam. We can't find Michael.
是啊。好吧，说到停车场，每个人都聚集在外面。凯文的钱押在帕姆身上。奥斯卡指出这是一场一边倒的战斗。这不是真的，你知道，帕姆赢是这里唯一的结局。好吧，现在没有迈克尔。只有帕姆。我们找不到迈克尔。
Meredith checks the men's room says the toilet seat is still warm. Thanks for putting your hand on the toilet seat, Meredith. I guess so. Kelly has made popcorn. Yes, she has. She's bringing snacks. And we find Michael in the stairwell. Yeah.
梅雷迪思检查了男洗手间，说马桶座圈还是热的。谢谢你把手放在马桶座圈上，梅雷迪思。我想是吧。凯利做了爆米花。是的，她做了。她带了零食。我们发现迈克尔在楼梯间。是啊。
He's clearly trying to psych himself up for this moment. And he walks out to the parking lot. And Pam is going to wind up. She's going to wind up for the punch. He flinches. And can I just say that Angela Martin for once is on Pam's side. Oh my gosh. Your line is so funny.
他显然在试图为这一刻振作起来。他走到停车场。帕姆要蓄力。她要为那一拳蓄力。他退缩了。我能说安吉拉·马丁破天荒地站在帕姆这边吗？天哪。你的台词太搞笑了。
Pam says, Michael, you have to put your hands down. Angela says, put your hands in your pockets. So this is just another person who is excited for Michael to get hit. Well, as Pam is getting ready to hit Michael, he actually stops. He apologizes to her for everything. Pam takes it in and she's like, okay. Okay. She says, fine, don't date anyone else in my family ever again.
帕姆说，迈克尔，你必须把手放下。安吉拉说，把手放进兜里。所以这只是另一个人为迈克尔被打感到兴奋。好吧，当帕姆准备打迈克尔时，他实际上停了下来。他为一切向她道歉。帕姆接受了，她说，好吧。好吧。她说，行，别再和我家里的任何人约会了。
And she's going to walk away. She is. But Michael cannot shut his mouth. Yeah. He says, for the record, your mom came on to me. Pam pivots on her heel. And slaps him so hard across the face. And she's got that super human pregnancy strength per Kelly.
她要走开了。她是。但迈克尔不能闭上他的嘴。是啊。他说，记录在案，是你妈妈主动勾引我的。帕姆在脚后跟上旋转。狠狠地扇了他一巴掌。而且她有凯利所说的超人怀孕力量。
We got a lot of mail. I might say fan mail flurry. Oh. Enoch N. from Pennsylvania wants to know, did Jenna really slap Steve? And Angela, Katie M. from Fresno, California said, quote, the moment Pam slaps Michael, I absolutely believe Jenna could have played Sydney Bristow on alias. Oh, Katie.
我们收到了很多邮件。我可能会说粉丝邮件狂潮。哦。来自宾夕法尼亚州的伊诺克·N想知道，珍娜真的打了史蒂夫吗？安吉拉，来自加利福尼亚州弗雷斯诺的凯蒂·M说，引用，“帕姆扇迈克尔的那一刻，我绝对相信珍娜可以在《双面女间谍》中扮演悉尼·布里斯托。”哦，凯蒂。
Okay, fine, Katie. I agree. This is a real Pam kick and some butt moment. Jenna, you nailed it. I am also curious because my character, as you know, slaps two people on this show and I really did hit my co-stars. Did you really hit Steve? I did not.
好吧，行，凯蒂。我同意。这是一个真正的帕姆踢屁股时刻。珍娜，你做到了。我也很好奇，因为我的角色，如你所知，在这个节目中扇了两个人，我真的打了我的联合主演。你真的打了史蒂夫吗？我没有。
Steve said I should hit him. It did not seem safe to me because I am whipping around. If it was just a slap from a standing position, but this was like, I could not bring myself to do it. I think that's really smart because I hit Mike sure on the run. Your whole body goes into it. And he discussed that slap on our podcast. Yes.
史蒂夫说我应该打他。这对我来说似乎不安全，因为我在挥舞。如果只是从站立位置扇一巴掌，但这就像，我无法让自己这样做。我认为这真的很聪明，因为我在奔跑中打了迈克·舒尔。你的整个身体都投入进去了。他在我们的播客上讨论了那一巴掌。是的。
Our stunt coordinator, Eric Solke. Love Eric. Yes. He gave me very detailed instructions on how to pretend slap Steve. And he also worked with Matt Sohn on positioning the camera behind me so that you couldn't even tell that I'm not hitting him. And then Randy told me that we added that slap sound in post-production. So I did not slap Steve.
我们的特技协调员，埃里克·索尔克。爱埃里克。是的。他给了我关于如何假装扇史蒂夫的非常详细的说明。他还和马特·索恩一起工作，把摄像机放在我身后，这样你甚至看不出我没有打他。然后兰迪告诉我，我们在后期制作中添加了那个巴掌声。所以我没有扇史蒂夫。
I'm glad you didn't because also you couldn't see him. Your back was to him. Yes. That's what I was worried about. I mean, I was worried that I might make contact, but I was very specific. Like we lined up our bodies. My pivot was highly choreographed. I just pivoted on that one spot.
我很高兴你没有，因为你也看不到他。你的背对着他。是的。那是我担心的。我的意思是，我担心我可能会接触到，但我非常具体。就像我们排好了我们的身体。我的旋转是高度编排的。我只是在那一点上旋转。
Yeah. You guys sold it. I thought it totally worked. Well, at the end, Michael is limping away. Limping. And Dwight's like, why are you limping? He's like, I don't know. Well, we had a fan question from MEL in Baltimore, Maryland.
是啊。你们卖力了。我觉得它完全奏效了。好吧，最后，迈克尔一瘸一拐地走开了。一瘸一拐。德怀特说，你为什么一瘸一拐的？他说，我不知道。好吧，我们收到了来自马里兰州巴尔的摩的MEL的粉丝提问。
Was Michael's limping and Dwight's reaction scripted or improvised? It was scripted. Yeah. When I reread the shooting draft, almost every single thing you see was completely scripted. All the little details. Mm-hmm. Well, fans had very mixed reactions to this slap. Yeah.
迈克尔的一瘸一拐和德怀特的反应是写好的还是即兴的？是写好的。是啊。当我重读拍摄草稿时，你看到的几乎每一件事都是完全写好的。所有的小细节。嗯哼。好吧，粉丝们对这一巴掌的反应非常复杂。是啊。
A lot of people felt like it was one step too far. They did not like Pam for doing this. I think Steve is so good at playing the vulnerable side of Michael. People were upset. How did we feel about it and rewatching it? I mean, I thought, you know, Pam was walking away. She wasn't going to do it. Mm-hmm.
很多人觉得这太过分了。他们不喜欢帕姆这样做。我认为史蒂夫非常擅长扮演迈克尔脆弱的一面。人们很不安。我们重看时感觉如何？我的意思是，我想，你知道，帕姆当时正走开。她本来不会做的。嗯哼。
And Michael just couldn't leave it alone. I think that collectively, I remember, the writers and producers felt that we couldn't end this story of Michael dating Pam's mom, doing this like highly insensitive thing to Pam. Not only did he date her mom, he then broke up with her mom on her birthday in a public place. And he needed a comeuppance. He needed, yes, he did.
而迈克尔就是不能让它过去。我认为总的来说，我记得，编剧和制片人觉得我们不能结束迈克尔和帕姆妈妈约会的故事，对帕姆做这种高度不敏感的事情。他不仅和她妈妈约会，他还然后在她生日那天在公共场合和她妈妈分手。他需要报应。他需要，是的，他需要。
Him and Pam needed to settle this. And now it's settled. It's not going to fester. So that was, I think, the reasoning behind it was that we needed to, this was now, it's been resolved. You know, there were a few relationships on the show that reminded me of siblings. Like Angela Oscar and Kevin, they were almost like siblings, you know? Stanley and Phyllis.
他和帕姆需要解决这个问题。现在解决了。它不会溃烂。所以那是，我认为，背后的推理是我们需要的，这现在是，它已经解决了。你知道，节目中有几段关系让我想起了兄弟姐妹。像安吉拉、奥斯卡和凯文，他们几乎就像兄弟姐妹，你知道吗？斯坦利和菲利斯。
And I felt like Pam and Michael were like brother and sister. I think that's a really good analogy. But yeah, I remember people were really chatting about this. Dwight is going to bring Michael inside and he says he's got some chicken. He can put on that. Call back to all that chicken on the microwave. Fan question from Victoria H. in Columbus, Ohio. Was Dwight holding real raw chicken on Michael's face or did Phil Shea make that?
我觉得帕姆和迈克尔就像兄弟姐妹。我认为这是一个很好的类比。但是的，我记得人们真的在谈论这个。德怀特要把迈克尔带进去，他说他有一些鸡肉。他可以放在那上面。呼应微波炉上的所有鸡肉。来自俄亥俄州哥伦布的维多利亚·H的粉丝提问。德怀特是在迈克尔脸上拿着真正的生鸡肉，还是菲尔·谢做的？
Well, both. It is real chicken that Phil Shea like shrink wrapped. So it was real, but it was like covered in something. So that. Gross. So gross. I thought for sure you're going to say no, it's a fakey rubber chicken thing. No, it was real chicken.
好吧，两者都有。那是菲尔·谢像收缩包装一样的真鸡肉。所以它是真的，但它就像覆盖着什么东西。所以那个。恶心。太恶心了。我以为你肯定会说不，那是一个假橡胶鸡东西。不，那是真鸡肉。
Wowzers. Yeah. Well Dwight thinks he finally did his favor and he says fire Jim. Michael's like no Dwight is angry and takes his dinner away. Yeah, he's going to eat that after it was on Michael's face. Apparently. You know, I feel like this episode wraps up best with the talking head that Michael had. Yes.
哇哦。是啊。德怀特以为他终于帮了迈克尔一个忙，他说解雇吉姆。迈克尔说不，德怀特很生气，还把他的晚餐拿走了。是啊，他居然还要吃掉那份沾过迈克尔脸的晚餐。显然是这样。我觉得这一集最好的结尾就是迈克尔的那个采访镜头。没错。
I feel like I need to read it. Okay, please do. As I watched Pam's big strong hand coming towards my face, I saw my entire life flashed before my eyes. And guess what? I have four kids and I have a hover car and a hover house. And my wife is a runner and it shows. And Pam and Jim are my best friends and our kids play together and I am happy and I am rich and I never die.
我觉得我得读一下。好的，请读吧。当我看到帕姆那只强壮的大手向我的脸挥过来时，我看到我的一生在眼前闪过。你猜怎么着？我有四个孩子，还有一辆悬浮车和一栋悬浮房。我妻子是个跑步运动员，身材很好。帕姆和吉姆是我最好的朋友，我们的孩子一起玩耍，我很幸福，我很富有，而且我永远不会死。
It doesn't sound like much, but it's enough for me. There you have it. There you have it. Michael in the end just sees them as his family. Always, always. Next week, you guys buckle in because it is murder. Oh, this is one of my biggest memes. Me too.
听起来没什么大不了的，但对我来说这就足够了。就是这样。就是这样。迈克尔最终还是把他们看作自己的家人。一直都是。下周，大家系好安全带，因为是“谋杀”那一集。哦，这是我最喜欢的梗之一。我也是。
People tag me all the time as voodoo mama juju. That was double date, everyone. Listen, check your glutes and maybe pick up some three penis wine. If your muscles are aching after your glute check, we should probably go get some right now, Ange. Skip the three penis wine. We love you. See you next week.
人们总是把我标记为“巫毒妈妈朱朱”。以上就是“双重约会”那一集，各位。听着，检查一下你们的臀肌，也许可以去买点三根阴茎酒。如果你们在检查完臀肌后肌肉酸痛，安吉，我们现在可能应该去买点。跳过三根阴茎酒。我们爱你们。下周见。
Have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
祝大家过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演唱的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要获得Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码OFFICE。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。